exactly what he wants to hear but this a
labor Party Conference dominated by what
the current government are doing a
political gamble now causing economic
pain but this isn't a board game it's
real life and today the bank of England
took dramatic action to calm the markets
it's a really very serious situation for
the bank of England to have to take that
action today on the back of the IMF
statement on the back of what the bank
of England said on Monday and this is a
self-inflicted wound the government has
lost control of the economy the labor
leader calling on the government to
recall Parliament and reverse measures
made on Friday
recall Parliament reversed the budget if
they do that we will act in the National
interest and we will support that to
ensure that no further damage is done is
list trust a dangerous prime minister
she's clearly lost control of the
economy and she needs to come to
Parliament straight away and reverse
that budget that's the responsible thing
to do do you think she's dangerous to
the economy well they've lost control of
the economy I'm not that's do you think
that's a
dangerous of course it's a danger they
took a huge risk risks this man has been
using to his Advantage as the Tories
make the biggest tax cuts in half a
century abolishing the top rate
disproportionately benefiting the
wealthiest in society just on the Prime
Minister she's on 164 000 so she
benefits from that top rate of tax being
part do you think she should give that
money to charity whatever profit she
makes from it maybe she should what she
should do which is more important than
that is to stop inflicting this damage
on working people because and that's the
direct action of her government and if
he was in government he'd shift away
from taxing workers incomes towards
taxing people's wealth income tax cuts
funded by wealth taxes is that the
direction of travel well in relation to
people who earn their income from stocks
and shares and dividends then yes we are
looking at what is a fair taxation
approach in relation to that we'll set
it out you know I think there's a lot of
thought that if you earn your income
through wages you paid a certain rate
but if you earn it through stocks and
shares and dividend you've had a
different rate that is something we need
to look so that's a broad shift isn't it
because at the moment the conservatives
seem to be taxing income yes or they
were until these big taxes they're
taxing income and they're impacting
working people the hardest and will we
soon see another much broader shift in
British politics I wonder whether when
you first took this job you thought you
might be more like Neil kinnick that you
might be the leader of the labor party
he's got the party ready to get into
power but it would take another cycle
and you weren't going to be the guy is
that fair do you think you've gone from
Clinic to Blair plenty of people when I
became leader lab party said good luck
here and then behind their breath said
but you'll never do it in one five-year
stretch here we are two and a half years
into my leadership
and a hope of a labor government has
turned into a belief of the labor
government so you're going to be our
next prime minister yes
but how to get there the elephant in the
room an election still two years out
everything to play for but what happens
next now anyone's bet Beth Rigby Sky
News Liverpool